please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded should be brief I thought
that it should be required high energy
when you please think room by the
taunton I'd escape staircase case hold
both handrails and praises there's a
little stripper if anyone is I types of
stairs played please allow other
stretches where people they go to the
fire escape door opening the hidden
assistance there are 74 to be in a
perfect are part of the scientist in
school please do not realizing the
evacuation text leader element these do
not returns the building and cook it
with please do so by the pension stuff
thank you the agenda apologies for
absence as the first Mason and he's
being substituted a by Catholic mounting
member apologies long limbs attending
the counselors son's been ok that's that
they come to the minutes of the meeting
house it with January counselor set home
has requested changes to the vehicles
the wording repaid was at all in rupees
the portfolio holder encourage members
to approaching if they have any ideas
for you see or particular assets they
that may have been overall so the
potential can be exported heard us he
felt that wasn't how he expressed it is
so rewarding was the portfolio holder
would encourage members to approach him
if there is any council I said that they
believe there is a better use for i'll
post between Burnett sorry customers I'd
like for my apologies in there because
that it didn't
um is that a great day three my three
great that's great
um
don't have some things as they own
mmm
I serve or to receive declarations of
interest has no reason thank you very
much I'll just want to ask that because
i use many of the different things
within the district Travis hall and
other places do I have to declare an
interest or is this differently all
together know that you're gonna be very
first because that's our learning I
can't I've discovery myself guess what
thank you they're no different features
Sonia we want to appoint some fine
medium so fine especially 2050 2020
you'll never see two papers will never
make you feel a greater level with
dreams night we will be looking at
recognition or page 5.1 which is a rock
for 4.1 recommendation and I'll now read
that out to the side now but that's what
this is what we are doing amazing it is
proposed that subject comments remembers
the committee results to know the
contents of the ntfs and recommend to
the full Prairie ahold of finance any
changes come budget process of
developing in other words in the
paperwork we've also received the paper
which will go to Council which is item
51 and that's the recommendations on the
background what not what we outside
right now on
how many photo to all caps on the side
so we're just deciding the
recommendation on the point of 14 nights
and five both doctors relevant threat
discussions going okay we'll start with
them councillor mounting and then we
move around a speak English Kate next
generation this referred members to page
five point two three a few questions
relating to the window that's why put it
on paper copy you can you're looking at
it on an orbital copy pasted in the
listen here somewhere yeah project
appendix it's not it's not ranged circle
magazine by 23 on Van top notes but it's
not medicine this on papers got my job
totally won't know what to work down a
bit and go through the questions that I
have starting at the premises related
the mill tower special items it goes
from 1300 up to 9300 down to 300 down to
500 on fact what these special items are
how about how can that be broken down
and there more to that that figure
specifically the 9300 can be understood
exactly what that contains the first
question the second question supplies
and services there's a big leap in the
under licensing from 500 to 1700 again
insisted question as to what that
relates to and
the depreciation what exactly is that
based on and the other maintenance costs
making up for that make sense and work
situations based on and support services
they just seem extremely high and I
wondered what you know what the
methodology was for is it based on
square footage how is how a support
services now is how they allocated was
the was the methodology behind them and
if it's possible to have a further
breakdown of fees and charges so I to
help us understand exactly what what the
feet incoming money is these weddings
leave my I'll stop from the bottom and
I'll take the ones i can answer and then
see if Matt can pick up the ones I can't
the income is weddings income so it is
just from weddings and we're forecast
the department are expecting to increase
income by advertising and publicizing
weddings and support services that is
all the wreath internal recharges so I'm
support services into the windmill it
will be mainly staff costs because you
don't have any direct salary costs
charged to this cost center depreciation
is based on the capital value the last
valuation of the windmill and
depreciated over expect for the windmill
to 30 years in public sector accounts we
have shut appreciation in the cost
center but unlike favorite sector it
then gets reversed out before it hits
capital tax that appreciation does not
have an impact on council tax but it's
so that you're you're showing a more
realistic cost of carrying your assets
and
if has made world special items I don't
think we're going to be able to give you
the breakdown see me so I have to come
back on that one and licensing I don't
know if you know the reason Moylan's but
my understanding that the licensing of
the window is 500 pounds a year but i
think they they're paying up front in 15
16 for three years worth plus inflation
cost but i will confirm let's go back to
the the example i understand the
internal recharging for this poor
services but what's what's what's
methodology was it worked out it will
depend because there will be recharges
from asset management so that would be
based on officer time there'll be one
other recharges going to windmill
management from the alleged manager the
legend manager so that would be a
percentage of his time based on whatever
recording he does so his challenges is
the correct then to to suggest that the
windmill is is making a loss of 161,000
403 pounds it's difficult to say because
mean support services we spend a fair
amount of time trying to do them
accurately but you could turn it into a
whole industry to get you know 100%
accuracy on your support services so
there is some estimating that goes into
that and he does depend when you ask so
the leisure manager how much time do you
spend on the windmill it will depend his
recollection might be that in the
previous week he was up the windmill on
guitar was if he'd actually done time
recording every day for a year you might
get a different percentage but now I
mean that is an indication of you know
your windmills costing the other thing
to consider is that where it is officer
time and it's ten percent of an officer
time if you lose the service you may not
necessarily lose the cost of salary
costs because you're just losing bits of
people
and in a small authority it's quite
difficult to bring all those bits
together to make a head that you can
lose that makes sense one hundred
thousand pounders at least one day yeah
but is no whose base is like there's
lots of other I mean what we can let you
have a breakdown of the support services
yes I am thank you shimmer I understand
that you're right that calculating
support services is an industry or a
science but I mean looking for the wind
wall in 2013-14 I comes to 146,000 if
you compare that a few pages on partners
to open space very support services
figures about twice that I know I'd be
surprised if if that was a fair malaysia
only the foot partners about the spaces
would take up a lot more time and
support services then we'll Mulder
rather than just twice as much and well
plots namespaces has employee costs
directly charged to the cost center so
there's some of the costs Cubbing you
know they're already there shown as
direct costs the windmill doesn't carry
a lot of direct costs they're just
related to premises and running costs
okay he was an onion
looking here the son of is cost look for
parks living spaces about 355,000 so
that's so now he had a point where even
allow it if you having the employee
costs apart snugglin spaces together the
vig virtually support services that's
about four times okay intuitive the
other sticky is still to be alive on
that he does seem to me the windmill is
getting charged a lot so I look for to
seeing more at the most fun yeah I think
it's a very difficult area it it's not
it's never going to be an exact science
and as you can almost straight away pick
up when you try and tribute these costs
to all the different services you can
pick holes but I do think it is right
the that some of it is done rather than
just having a big pot of money that
provides an amount of services you need
to try have some go at attributing it to
thee that the particular items that of
course this can cancel amounting said
though it looks like it's a very
expensive resource but that's just
simply matched against the income from
weddings the big intangible is the
number of people through the door the
value that you place on those the value
of the asset to the town and it could be
that if you wanted to spend time on
essentially a bureaucratic equation you
could come out that windmill is
exceptionally good value for money and
though them sort of cut staff costs are
a drop in the ocean but it's it's it's
nothing that the calculations that do
need to be done in some form you can't
just pay them lip service but
nevertheless their calculations that
don't give much bending to anyone other
than just the ability to examine it
on the periodic basis so casual about it
Qatar's there is the support services is
it is the equation saying throughout all
support services nine so hey char will
be based on number of staff finance we
do on the number of invoices paid number
of invoices raised on the number of
staff on the payroll a breakdown of
senior officers time that will then gets
weighted by salaries to come up with a
percentage asset management is done on
floor space and the asset management
program was we've got legal is done on
time we call Dean computer services is
done on time recording number of PCs and
licenses valuations phone call reception
is done on number of phone calls
premises on square foot occupied and
information support services is time
recording number of post items so what
we do is look at a portion down head and
there's they come at the end of the
budget book and decide the most
appropriate basis for how you're going
to apportion that overhead and then
decide on a realistic way of getting the
data to then calculate the recharge but
there'll be a different method depending
on the cost grounds maintenance is done
on the suite schedule of a loss for the
contract the bells maintenance contract
but if you gave me a full-time
accountant I'd be quite happy and it
would be a lovely job I just don't
actually do that job spend the whole
year doing me charges yeah I was was
related that's a question I couldn't see
anything about pet cemetery in here I
needed to come under 5.26 Memorial trees
and benches or does it come under Jerry
what you are owed pity it wasn't listed
down the the pet cemetery income there
hasn't been any income yet there's one
pet to be buried within the next couple
of weeks which would be the first one so
at the time of setting putting these
estimates together it was unknown as to
how much income would be generated so
when we come to do revised estimates in
September of this year then an income
stream budget line will be put in for
that micro that will be 60 pounds it is
60 pounds per per burial yes and what
amount has been spent on it and it's its
capital expenditures no revenue
expenditure it's incorporated within the
Cherry Orchard country park capital
budget so the losses Lee yes thank you
very much the pet cemetery is something
that is a new one and I personally have
realized that in all possibility when
probably has a pet it put in their or
their ashes whatever it is they will
want to have a tree or something put
there in memory of them and in the hope
that they would then by the tree through
the district council and if it's
possible it will come through our
woodlands officer and so that's going to
give us more income not just the berry
the animal but to actually to get the
income
I'll show that on this because it's a
new thing and I personally very much
involved in this and I feel that we are
going to get more people interested in
going to cherry orchard and across the
people from outside and it's going to be
as time goes on it's going to be a
bigger attraction to bring people into
Oxford and that's why I'm looking at it
you can't put any costing on it yet
because it's only just beginning and if
you can okay you'll see where the area
is I'm going to trees a bitter as the
trees trees have been planted over there
now outlining the First World War
pathway and that's in that same area so
it's something else we as an authority
are doing to encourage people to come a
visit us so that is all for us getting
more money and thank you ok I'll sit
sort of yeah I was probably what the
funding was for the redevelopment where
you say let you know it was it's not a
no show me you get out sorry dick mell
were from any era afterwards why are you
did he do go there was an officer
they've to get me put into office an
Arctic dowel if you know I think I'll
for use or well it's made costs involved
it's only just for the folks house where
we snip huge blue chip sorry darlin I'll
do apologize I think I'm saying both
questions of our anti-drug mission
understand them has it been to answer
this where I used move our capital cost
Richard maybe noob cost us both these
companies by the attacks across boom
really I spoke to the assistant director
for that area today and he estimated
twenty thousand but that's not accurate
figure we can provide mackerel capital
costs for the article charity run walk
with with the cost that the cut across
that there was God but the idea was that
would generate a revenue stream and its
failed well it's only it's only just
been completed
that in there just been completed and
the first one is in the diary and your
pending more to come in from a German
army slowly the the term capital costs I
think suggests something like business
arrangement I think capital investment
is perhaps a slightly easier term
because it is an investment in the
future it is an investment in equality
of life it is fairly intangible in terms
of how people evaluate it's something
that will take quite a considerable
number of years in terms of you know the
graveyard of any kind I very much doubt
their their money-making operations
however the investment and the worth of
them is immeasurable so just in terms of
that level of understanding you it
wasn't it was never intended as a
specific business plan as I understand
league is at this moment in time council
nothing cost strawberry festival booking
didn't eat but I counselor no sauce no
bishop does anyone else have any bacon
to this place
then that's are often I think I hear an
amazing just mention that counselor
birds and it's a team will be late
because entrees some why apologies for
not giving his apologies be late so it's
a terrible one um took a town in sorting
out his next one can I ask my question
that I wanted to ask you should lay off
my question was the money that it cost
probably of the long you're going to ask
about the legal costs oh yes in the
legal custom we've had to pay to do with
the going to court for we would believe
it out really the case that we happen to
have to employ a solicitor's or
barristers to it and as I understand
it's something like about 50,000 it's
gonna cost that the residents of the
district through it can I be assured
that although i know it doesn't come
through with an insurance claim or
anything is it going to make much
difference to how we waste that money
and if I waste that is dead to be using
it elsewhere can that be found in this
year's budget without increasing it yeah
we are pleased we put money away in a
reserve in anticipation of costs and the
amount put away will cover our costs and
margins come back then please mr.
chairman the second thing is as and when
if they go to appeal will be then again
have to find monies for that as well yes
if they if they went to appeal we have a
planning appeals reserve thank you
that's all I wanted was thank you very
much thank you um cuz miss especially
with a question for you ever noticed on
going through the number of times that
car allowances come up was the car
allowances
full car petrol for one it's it's a
better car allowance for essential car
users they'll be reducing because the
new appointments on senior management
team my beginning Carl ounces and it's
mileage claims but the council doesn't
provide cars okay yeah I would if I
could follow up from Casa glints going
there we go in the court costs would
that explain why on five page five point
13 from your evil has gone in a lot of
20,000 pounds yes yeah it's um yeah we
talked to the planning manager about
unlegal about the number outstanding
appeals all those that we think are
going to come through and we put money
in the budget if it's not spent at the
end of the year we'll make a decision
about whether to put that into a reserve
to build up funds if we've got any large
peels of thick might come through so to
be clear on that one in this was his
on-base they think how do girls will
increase that he's gone up to 20,000 and
now it's just that when we did when we
closed the accounts of thirteen fourteen
we decided that there was enough at that
point in the reserve not to put any
money or ways that's why the strictly
it's only showing three and a half
thousand expense I was returning to yes
Prince
joan callamezzo has says officials throw
a fight you'll need arrives and if he
doesn't arrive we ask the name depending
on trains I did ask a few questions
myself which I form on down the battery
out quick email and tongue for the page
numbers friction but at the same time
the duplicated bit amazed division of
people the first ones in park sizes
spaces we should be around 40 page 25 to
35 on top notes I mean trolley failing
there we have to finally be sociable
under contracted services the bottom of
bag is virtue at the bottom they had
contract contingency they've confirmed
sort of 2013-14 exact revenge but there
were three hundred centuries come to
50,000 when we market when I say the
word contingency on normally a bit wary
because it means to me that it's just
there just in case we might need it for
something that we deserve a rationale
for that already neighborhoods of why we
leave that money yeah gehen I've spoken
to the assistant director for this area
today and fifty thousand pound was set
aside in case the new grounds
maintenance contract failed and the
reason for that contingency was because
the grounds making contact ho mean a lot
lower than was expected they wanted to
keep that there
for that very reason in case of failure
that be normal behavior with a new
contract I think with the history of
grounds maintenance in in the past that
we've had then it was prudent from Rick
hasn't man yeah I would agree i think he
was cluded I was older than the panel
but looked at the new contract and yes I
think it I think he was prison
definitely better than one what happened
previously yeah is there a time limit on
which will be providing for it i mean
these are a certain way into the
contractor will feel confident we won't
need to continue field or is that more
being thoughtful yet we have we have
considered it it's a short column was a
short contractors news for four years
with extensions and the you know the
vista might increase near the end of the
contract so at this point in time the
advice would be to leave it in so at the
end of the contract potentially would
have built up a reserve of 200 risotto
to increase my 200,000 pounds if it
doesn't get used to effective general
fund yeah some financing you just don't
you suppose to yeah oh yeah you are we
on that page so on that cherry orchard
country park then the fingers go from 98
19 to 43 100
that's not me some types of services i
miss link to the Cherry Orchard grant
that's then on the next page so there's
an expenditure that's one funded so you
got fifty nine thousand pounds of grant
that's coming in yeah we have to show
the income and expenditure separately
mr. chairman can I ask a question on
that you goof um is that that's
calculated for one year and that amount
of money getting the grant does that
then come back to the grants being
available from different organizations
and so on yeah there's what they've had
grant money for specific things and then
they've got grants that are going to
last I think up to 10 years from the
Forestry Commission so we're expecting
59,000 in this year 37 and a half
thousand next year but we're not
expecting large amounts 16 17 going on
words thank you very much so if i just
come back to the routine you see p.m.
2000 it does come back hours in college
case i mean that size effectively typing
off to take the dates is pretty soon as
i continue to see as a lot as you may
have but then once the librarian really
like not realized why there's not gonna
be a lot better soon take me as income
accounts that there's a great spot
summer spaces to gradually reduce them
the expense yea or no go yeah we're not
expecting to prevent it this year yeah
so that's how it be treated again
doesn't income that be written back to
you if it's not used to so the two other
girls
the next one was about Lee s control
community and that case a light source
500 roses obviously selfish present the
Hawaii yeah um released I walk there was
an emergency fund for previous years for
20 of these on page 52 I just want what
evidence there was that we need eight
and where the value of 40,000 have come
from and like the usage in previous
years of beef i'll pick you up about
3000 laughter utiful yes seven wondrous
approach number please I'm sorry almost
all people so seven we spent 700 33
pounds in 1314 who spent 4499 pounds in
12 13 11 12 was the transfer road 4033
9063 700 yeah so
the 40,000 is a best estimate the demand
for pest control service that deals with
that's the mice or some debate of the
away day about extending it to different
types of insects that the consensus was
that that would just open the authority
up to two too much cost and Simon will
explain the rationale for including it
in terms of their evidence it's not it's
not just the demanding sled idea that
there's a degree of political intent
behind this one we've got on concert say
anything else dealing with pests is
something of a crisis situation and when
we've when we've had crisis situations
before albeit somewhat significant more
significant than rats or mice we do
understand that people look to the
counseling to deliver some sort of
service and if the if the councilman's
suggestion is I've been a bit flippant
here to go and buy some bugs of being
queue or to go and get the other pages
and look up pest control service and see
if they're open on a Sunday afternoon or
whatever it happens to be I think that
the council might open itself up to a
certain amount of ridicule so we have
we've seen that there is a perceived
need and it's a service that the public
would appreciate as providing now when
you start up an idea like this
essentially for free you could expose
yourself to untold expenditure the the
advice that we've had from officers is
that we should look specifically
things that are connected with public
health as opposed to public nuisance and
it seems that wasps is the line in the
sand because wasps are public nuisance
as opposed to public health and there's
debate about about that however rats
mice vermin we are looking at getting
together a formal plan for doing that
we're looking at weather we're having
token charges completely free or a level
of charges the scheme is not fully
developed at this stage but an allowance
needs to be made for the scheme to to
come and of course the success of the
schemes partly going to be influenced by
the amount of its advertised whether we
start off with a slow burn with word of
mouth whether we go out to everyone and
just tell them through our DM or
whatever Avenue that it that it's that
we've not fully decided yet we're going
to work closely with officers so that we
can enter this new arrangement in a in a
sensible way those are our initial
Russian army I love you just remember to
thank you all know this subject how was
the 40,000 being allocated Awards
whereas that being spent and was there
ever an option to have linked up with
with Castle points and
shared service across the weather is
good there's a variety of options that
could be considered as I say that
they're not all all there yet but i
think our scheme will be very much for
watch for rather than trying to put back
on me and back to someone else's it
could be that we use our our own stuff
to deal with this it could be that we
simply use a contractor to come in and
deliver the service the detail is not
fully evolved yet but all those things
own possibly possibly more I'm sure will
be considered do we know the cost to the
caps do the last year that we to operate
them just the CMAs nope i think it was
obviously useful for a BBQ moving 11-12
it was twenty-one thousand but i think
the scheme changed part way through the
year that's all we were moving away from
providing comprehensive services yes um
where I live I've had to attack three
times that I've had have them in to see
to the wasps where I live and to find
that they're in the roof and to be
honest it's a big a huge like that and I
can they give them three or four up and
the whole lot is finished and done with
under five minutes and then they go and
they don't come back in that particular
area that that cost something like 50 60
pounds to do that and I are quite
honestly as far as I'm concerned I was
pleased to pay it to get rid of them but
I think if we're going to look that
people can apply at ernst it to
happening this this Fermi take the main
I'm talking about the one of the wasps
in my opinion it should be just that as
we do now the family into the council
and they give you somebody's number two
or three numbers
you can't do it yourself because once
they that that nest has gone they're
gone for good I know that because I've
had them in various parts of my ground
and I think it's something that in my
opinion people should be able to find
the man in themselves to do it it is a
one-off thing that's finished with it's
not like the rats and mice it's a
different thing altogether I think
they're not doing what's really scream
not was it's a split the dot bees I'm
talking about water about an album
what's up to this game so it counts just
sort of our on a point of caution and if
we were doing a free service was I'm
sure we would be absolutely inundated if
you know I'm absolutely not an ecologist
but I suspect if we were to essentially
Radek a wasps and rupture district I
mean people say they're not useful in
sector of any kind but that's good
that's going to be affecting something
somewhere along the line and we we have
to approach something like that with a
very cautious aria I think because the
Milton's just want to come back to it
was coming to us to find the page of
time what's the 400 right on the has
treatment so the actual 2013-14 400 when
the original to 2000 is that what we
spent on it this was 400 s er they're 13
14 was faint has to spend yeah so we go
as we no longer provides we no longer
provide a free service the proposal is
to provide a free service just I think
we do provide a leader probably did we
have a hardship so if someone's on low
income they can approach the council
God and the council may business costs
as 400 pounds and 300 333 pounds it's
those two lines right but I'm just
questioning that what kind of suspicious
about that they're being perceived a
moment for the service but she's fun
well because people know who don't
provide service with David up to bring
up the council to ask for the service
whereas people who are say on receiving
benefits may be directed to the service
that we currently provide for those on
low income do we know how many
complaints we've had we've received
about not providing a free service we
haven't received any complaints in the
last year and I don't know how many
complaints where you all comments we
received when we first stopped to
provide in it still give real castle
there yeah couple of points first of all
kempster Smith talked about how people
will contact the council and quite often
my look for information five-mile
council website and as you if you just
type in that moment is the council
website you give a page but it's quite
informative message that he says first
of all the council know that provides a
little pest control service we just
cover some other information there and
so I think because some things are hard
to search for any chance a website
that's is in the beginning once about
pressing the work quite well I would
support bring the service pack we always
used to have it I think it's a proposal
as Kansas consider mr. public's health
and function there but it's not
vaccination you want everybody to be
vaccinated to keep down disease you want
every way to get their backs of our
house to keep their own blacks disease
elsewhere so is something I would
support and it's not a it's not a
massively expensive suicidal
mr. chairman his cousin I'm sorry but we
used to have a rat catcher and he lived
at raw earth and he had the most
wonderful allotment and he was what he
was the map one character that everybody
knew him oxfords then I'll say if you're
going to look to something like that
they take somebody on it's going to cost
a lot of money a vehicle and everything
else and I think the way is nowadays and
the way you can eradicate the uberman is
a much better ways and cheaper in the
number of people to do it themselves yes
thank you so disparate rebel regiment um
moving forward tons of the other
questions own great athletes formation
around the young air quality review on
in I think we're all aware that there is
a high quality thing management area
area radial artery is they increased
12,000 in relation to that the trial for
the placement as motivation sorry I'm
hugging every other page that the pages
on 5.37 so it goes onions so to 12,000
pounds every year is that what we should
normally spend on this problem perhaps
haven't last year yeah then i can give
you the breakdown of what the 12,000
pound is earmarked for nine thousand
pound of it is for a continuous
automatic analyzer which is actually one
around them there's a one and a half
thousand pound contract with chunks but
borough council for an annual progress
report which includes a maintenance of
the website and then the actual
diffusion tubes that they use in the air
monitoring itself cost in the region of
5 to 700 pounds
to replace so the 90,000 pounds
something we would spend every euros
that because of the Air Quality
Management probably been railing um no I
think that is something that they well
that's what they're planning on spending
I don't know if we should spend that in
the past but that is for the 12,000
pound budget go forever don't remember
checking their recordings oh there's a
few ups and downs of salaries in Arabic
as a Burton you hopefully be able and
usually also questions around changes in
salaries for instance i noticed hackney
carriage licensing justify the painful
Pradesh's by you 9341 and this one other
there's a big drop in salaries name yes
we had a bit of it because we do the S
will start the estimates in August and
then we'll continue reviewing and
revising them one of the challenges just
this year has been redesigned well we
haven't you no dignity 19th of January
who might be appointed in 2 posts so
what we did just because it because
those costs impact on support service
recharges we pulled out all the senior
management team costs into one cost
center so the transportation manager
when over it is in senior management
cost center her costs came out pat
mckerrod so there's just a bit of up and
down on some of the young salary budgets
that probably explains that's my
signature which for the bureau post see
national team why's it such a success
here is that because you play we assume
everyone is now yes so the young the 13
14 and 14 15 costs were just heads or
service costs and the reduction in 1415
revises because we've been carrying two
vacancies I've
last year and then the increase to
900,000 is because all the assistant
directors and the director posts are now
in this cost center but the actual
salary costs were her the whole of the
senior management teams about 1.6
million so there is about an eight
hundred thousand is about an eight
hundred thousand pound saving on salary
costs as a result the redesign so if you
want where that pageboy open on 40 mm
team mmm the PAS appointing there as
well they used to sit an individual
prosthetics so that's the reason why
there's ice cream yes babies not I'm
desperate hundred repeat Oklahoma behind
highways is horrible yes don't ask me a
patient under someone completely
different and you asked about the 35,000
do this was a young 5.47 right-click for
7-12 of those are valid anymore them and
the reason under supplies or services we
have strength stroke for pub 19 and in
2015-16 we've got yes but those up to
35,000 just for that one yes and this is
discussed in the covering report so this
was a budget bid firm counselor at first
and so it's arising out her and her
working group on part night lighting one
body realize it was that much yes yes so
it's a one-off provision to allow the
working group to do research publicity
and just you know do some useful work
around the whole part night lighting
issue so the advisory group for a budget
of thirty thirty thousand thousand right
it's a rule that his time here normally
it's 5,000 which is because there are
some street lights that are our
responsibilities very very few
have really doing terrible that 30,000
would be useful young we receive she an
exchange with unfilled I think she did a
verbal didn't she at the young
I've no it was I mean I have got more
information because I'm Catholic person
went into some detail at the array de
bola included with the detailed research
and analysis but it's not to pay for
turning lights on because that would be
an uncommon going liability on page
thirty-four thousand 51 you seem
interesting parallel roughly seven 590
Roger browse related to that he says in
order to support the work of the room
including detailed research and analysis
ton of money 11,000 were found for
2015-16 I'm a bit surprised by the nice
what the number was pretty it's injured
quite a lot turn off the lights over
here for that I think counselor
McPherson indicated that most of that
money wouldn't be used in vent that's
that's the impression I that I've been
seven sorry guys disease of coffee yeah
I've seen to be the only one that's not
true but I'm sorry but i would prefer to
see that we have that money in bear that
if we need to use it it's there rather
than take it down to half of it then
find at a summit particular moment we
certainly haven't got that money
available is surely a good husbandry is
to have something there in the case of
an emergency and i would think that that
is for that that's how i see it it's
like a salute you what sort of emergency
no idea with an advisory group so there
could be an emergency from it that
they've got to do something urgently I'm
not on it so I wouldn't know but what
I'm saying is so it's a very well to
city and say well we shouldn't do this
and we shouldn't do that but we've got
to be an authority that the cameras that
something goes wrong we have the reserve
there to do it without fiddling around
because we've got it there come back
within yes it was just to say that this
is a new budget so it's a recommendation
to full council so it's not yet you know
a definite budget and you'll have an
opportunity at council next week to
debate the merits of whether it go you
know it stays in the budget book or not
just go get me go right we clearly
haven't got that's the specifics of that
information for you tonight yeah we can
ask out some a person to feed that to
you unless it's something that you feel
would be more appropriate to just
examine in front of cancer so I guess
there's drove everything city has
because you never that cost will include
some sort of officer time perhaps as
well yes I mean I've got I mean Council
Macpherson's original email was very
very brief and she provided a lot more
information at the away day but it did
include officers time promotion of the
part night lighting group a website
public consultation and research and
analysis because I think one of the
issues is we don't know how many lights
and where the lights are
a better girl code test which the
council Atlanta yeah i think in addition
to that it was to make residents aware
of who was responsible for what like
somewhere so that there was no confusion
and to be quite sure that residents
raining to to get the correct
information who to go to and and and how
easy it was to get those sorted out
because there's been quite a number of
problems with life that have been looked
at least in part lop part night lighting
but in fact as being lights that are not
working and if the residents were
assured knew exactly where to go to that
would be amazing and it isn't it is a
one office so I mean when we've got the
flood prevention of 25,000 each year
this is just one of them amount which i
think you know we do need to be looking
at that absolutely yeah i mean the door
panel but caps on the first and set up
and you know they're not like some
progress on this I'm not clear what
35,000 be useful of a vote i can i can
see a situation where officer time is
spent on this subject in terms of we're
talking about earlier apportioning
officer time and i think you can come
into that old if a panel is getting the
council to carry out safety audits or
let me get the county to carry out
safety willits i might be arranging our
own independent safety woods uncertain
bikes to see if they should be on or off
but emily's challenging become his
decision or particular like some
particular boat we might need a space um
officer time to talk about about i think
it's the best version out so for having
me what was going to agree with counsel
butcher and Castle black widow on the
environment as well as we probably dig
deep on Thursday five minutes ago boom
what personally would like a bit more
information for the full council wisdom
as per my recommendation I think perhaps
that running quite make it up here for
men all members yes if we had to be a
police tell us about when I think as the
backs mentions cycles which makes
perfect sense to make buns you hear
they're not gonna be cheap so I can
understand that guitar d then there's a
budget which I didn't understand before
I think that would be very useful for
members of a head details of that
pervade over the full council meeting
thank you cast emancipatory those 11
that we discussed earlier it's on page
five point four three two one figure is
916 pounds the budget is 5,500 pounds it
was very determined well we do graffiti
we have done that since 730 didn't
approve
home today yeah another oh I think we
had a discussion before me to that and
one things came up is why aren't we wild
while we're spending 5,500 while we only
spent 916 it will depend on what gets
reported to the council so if goofy tea
for some reason isn't being reported two
councillors have been spotted by the
officers they're out and about then the
expenditure might be lower in a
particular year what would that
expenditure send spent on purely
graffiti removal purely graffiti removal
on on council buildings or public
buildings where it's been reported in to
the department and the definition that
we watch our district council buildings
already any council buildings will
include bus stops or things we will try
and go after the landowner but if the
land owner refuses to do to remove the
graffiti and for whatever reason if it's
offensive council officers decide that
you know the council needs to remove it
then we'll remove it and then try and
recover the costs from the landowner but
that's not always possible if it's
derelict building and I know in the past
we've struggled with the railways
getting money back off the railways
and add some stupid council diversities
in here I'll help out through some of
the Pharisees raised the first one is on
the Innovation Fund what they use for a
wise wise it's no more all right and
this was a one off about 8 feet agreed
as part of the 14-15 budget where we
took out a number of vacancies and put
the money from those vacancies into a
pot of money 75,000 over 11 it was them
the chief executive is keen to have an
innovation fund that would provide money
to pump climb projects that would
generate income or have demonstrable
benefits to the council they haven't
used all the money this year so we've
reduced it 60,000 and anything that's
not spending this year will go into a
reserve and be used it for any projects
that come up next year it's the role of
yes yes there was I think visit Essex
and openness cinema and there was
another one but I remember which one it
got it was there was a two years
something like tourism you don't ask
your eyes I've seen quite a bit I love
how their reason it was realistic yeah
but it was a portfolio holder to
portfolio holder reports on the details
of the project and concealing had
resumed authorities that management has
to be done for the readers of conducting
elections which is to be near the front
5.19 further on the question mark has
got an ID was it a slow progression of
these just a carrot paper he says a few
my next year's a huge boundary changes
and the subsequent elections of you be
positive
it's the umlaut elections in 2016
presume this year arsham is a general
election height yes lecturers all data
collection then the year after
sketchy-ass collection obviously that's
wallet and then 2017 I to interview
there's no e deck no no disks council
elections everything changes their
number this one is the emergency padding
elbow safely 203 5 730 first aid courses
5.2 15 21 the the increase from 6900 is
it the increase from 6902 2398 revises
be including the 20 3900 isn't just for
first aid courses whereas the 6900 was
the 23 900 includes the cost of six
emergency encore offices whereas their
salaries were situated wherever their
staff costs were represented here
instead of having them spread out with
called them into one budget so part of
their salaries each one will you that
that's the total emergency is all salary
3,000 pound each alrighty extra they're
playing piano scoffing at me right now
next one I think I'm probably understand
is one built just in care of occasion
local name for Jesus the variance page
for 22 there are something no salaries
there
we have this debate and the budget book
doesn't reflect the structure of the
council so the land charges lady used to
be in legal services then a few years
ago land charges moved into customer
services and we had two mates about
whether the salaries should show under
land changes and I won that debate at
that point in time but I've obviously
lost the argument going forward and it's
in I think it's in cus customer services
and so now it's part of the recharge as
port services of the things i think on
services yeah i was thinking behind it
is then for someone's salary to sit
under there under the cost center they
should be doing fifty percent or more of
their work on that cost center and for
the land charge officer less than fifty
percent of her work is his on land
charges so she sits under where majority
of that isn't that's customer services
and didn't mail which I think we
discussed the lady with warranty costs
separate I quite understand at seven
that's five point two
23 amazing this one it's belen yeah I
mean hmm that's the question but when I
understand you probably because his two
lines it's a wing no running costs oh
yeah by God's David and I don't know why
what would the extra line 500 pan is
fire to find out for you just I resolute
cretins you vary the licensing 500
pounds of them next one is measured
premises vegetable though is paisa
basements seems alone so we have
currencies the first line page 5.0 for
the implications for each property that
that repairs and maintenance line switch
those properties is purely for the car
parks of those properties we don't take
up the repairs and maintenance for the
building's themselves
ok any questions on that could I um
clarification ground watts paintings we
as a council name now pain an ndr on
national non-domestic rates on I
understand we've taken something else
but it on Oh still quite surprised by
that why don't people we still came from
the parades and we hear me it's connect
assistive the front own existence a
great way to clear Sports Center and
they use the safe centers returns lately
yeah which I would understand the only
ones not under fusions control box crows
is that my still for clarification yeah
you should know my national anthem is
knee brace for the do is a control yeah
we're still paying twenty percent of a
hospital of your clothes viola just
enjoy
customers next question was the one
we've done on straight lighting as well
so that's that they put it down any
crazy to school advisory builds there's
no problem the next one was on the waist
15 16 they won't be in the Reverend
budget that we part the capital program
Susan oh yeah yeah she's done
independence orders that yeah so he's
just knocking while this is just the one
year what with us why'd you leave with
some part of the extension of the
recycling contract and they can't
contract say to provide the vehicles as
part of the contract price and the
extensions negotiated on the basis that
council can access cheaper financing so
we're financing the cost of the vehicles
for the seven year extension so it's
about I think three hundred thousand
pound revenue saving from this capital
investment the plan is if the council
can dispose of some assets is to conduct
through internal blowing so as general
fund balances are going up there's
enough cash flow for the council to fund
this is eternally rather than going
externally
whoever says page won't put 116 in
appendix 4 caption program its has been
explained file when is fairly basic 2056
they will find three vehicles return
funding yeah so they've been it'll be
rough on waste coming to be there being
run by the way some people they're being
run by the district council and you'll
see the revenue saving on page five
point four four and the college wrinkles
yeah so much taking look into account
inflation the savings about 300 yes
there will the patient's I've got here
elevations which are being passed to me
two hours if I typical meditative any
questions I'll start with castor seeds
and just look around see if anyone catch
mine and no one does so phase sorry
customs is people yes we're stuck here
for or over now we're going through all
of this am i right in thinking there
will be a written reply to all these
questions and when we have the full
council next week if these questions
won't be asked again because they would
I take it they will be answered in a
written form yes none of these questions
will come up am i right in that mr. will
be within a within our minutes
discussions where we are often
equation ax has been brought forward to
the full council such as I I would like
us to ask can we have the clarification
around the 30 thurs penalty advisory
group in a bit more detail so all
members understand what it's for because
there are members there who haven't
heard he has well again but it could be
for safety listings of that I think he
gives cap charity so yes those hope you
would be within it but just entity
members who are members of reviews which
moist announcements own wishes we got
fish here they haven't been diminished
lovely roses sorry because it's been
advised councillor McPherson a couple
ready than the informations yet okay
she's whether I go yeah there was just
one small change that happened to the
figures from that you presented with the
away J which it probably wouldn't notice
cancel that was all the worries on page
91 in top notes I mean 22 and it's just
fees and charges with regard to
cemeteries and there was a the this
charge charge the barrels but there was
a it was a charge was stillborn and
under under one month and then looking
at it it just didn't feel right it was a
it was only one occurrence last year
ball fortunately but we remove that and
it's just a small thing but I think it's
important and no one wants to take
credit for it I think it's just to make
people aware of it this way [ __ ] we
enjoy money
mapleton earlier no charge of them it's
very castle back yep I mean I think it's
available idea and I'll all the
sentiment behind it I mean it is
interesting because you get that I
previous uses because you say the only
mon nasty and I see it under 12 years
that there were no charges and I'm
wondering that's like that there were no
no there were no occurrences after years
of chute number 12 I'm just wondering if
we should look about at some stage as
well same way
it's not la mean there's nothing sorry
chairman nothing stopping you proposing
that next week i I don't I don't want to
make it a full council being in there
yes but it is something I don't
understand about it but I think I was
the veneer well I'm sorry and in my
introduction I could just mention it's
an amendment when i introduced the
report i under the mechanism proof of
that I'm a human I'll talk to Albert
cattle when you're saying it obvious
even if I'd been using about today
leadership that will do councillors
asleep yes on that subject they wanted
to younger children alive no no in the
last few years of force that he passed
away and variably they have been gone
into a dist num district symmetry
they've gone into the church symmetries
are crashing down and so on and so it
doesn't show and it goes through a
completely different section and being
your mind that all of you how to say I
fully agree but I think children under
12 shouldn't they should they've got to
pay the expenses for the funeral and
everything else and I think we should
take it out of have asked about domain
that it is been free the the the
symmetry part of the district council
and I think that should really come out
of people realize that that that cost is
taken away
that's that recommendation is that we
are subjects and comments from members
today the committee results to know the
contents of him PMS and Brittany remote
control New Republic currently from
folio and hold of the phone is any
changes to the budget process for
2016-17 have we got any moved on to the
process now and it will confuse
apparently the process of it either this
is talking about the away days and how
they work and the timing of them are
there some problem around timing given
the fact that we often don't know what
the government because they now we take
it on Christmas Christmas Eve there are
going to comment or do they think the
process worked better this year than the
previous year mr. Chairman I would like
to i personally would like to say this
one having it back at saxon hall was so
much better for everyone not only for
parking and and finding the place and
the food and in the way that we were
treated there i thought it was excellent
i only have one comment to make but
instead of as a year before we took a
number and a pot and we set at that
table this time people SAT with their
friends and neighbors and so on and my
only comment is I think the idea that we
sit with whoever is on that table with
the number i think it's much better than
staying in the same group but again i
would like to congratulate yvonne
because i thought she did an extremely
good presentation and i thought that
when each table had the two of them
questionnaires to do and so on it was
very very informative and I do know a
member that sat next to me that isn't
here tonight no names no pack true he
was very impressed
paperwork that he took away with him so
congratulations you got and all your
team it makes them such as the fishermen
I'll agree with counsel agreement on
those two comets the way they
particularly would be cast to the
numbering so you can umber and use an
attacking with a problem it was stopped
everybody seeing the government's
request isn't as well friends better
baby I'm going to pull us out a little
bit automatically private confidential
something corporate rarity when it when
perhaps Chatham House Rules multiply
where you you could talk to people about
what may have been discussed without
tributing anything else that's my only
comment really around it weren't there I
know that's why didn't attention I'm
counselor back yeah I mean I'm wizard
mixed views about your way they say I
think if accounts was fun properly you
shouldn't need them we should be able to
take the council chamber save money and
you can do it in a more rigorous basis
going to agree that the office of
information was very good as you always
is I'm not convinced that the wood we
have these that we always have this kind
of little session where we may be having
it wilt a studio and talk amongst
ourselves and that wasn't behind light
of the day that feels like that and I
really doubt whether this little hot
this essence of what vote vote but part
of that other exercises are worth what
artists and also provide violet if
they're going to have this I've got on a
baton shutup house is always welcome
Pete see and I don't think you messaged
sure you sit with cata sleepers and they
care but the whole point of chess and
hence rules is that you it stays within
those four walls not enables some
free-thinking so yeah the envelope
basically so the ideas can be discussed
you know you can act as you wish as
devil's advocate or vice versa tempted
to actually draw out means of in our
case usually try and save money and
still provide as good or better services
at the interval so I just sometimes that
will be a rather difficult or involve
are the difficult concepts which you
know members might be deterred well
actually quality quite annoying if you
like but see how probably the general
feeling is on a particular idea Peppa
back come back young as I think there is
some disagreement of what children house
ones me or misunderstanding Chatham
House Rules mean but you can repeat
anything that said move in those four
balls but you can't say who said it
that's what certain houses are that's
not wise to a real pricey to the system
for the devil that's the way operate
simply to preserve as far as I'm aware
so really really lot of dishes how long
city's library as a black line a few
oppressive yes I mean I creature
aesthetic sent because I think in a
situation like that to have a certain
amount of confidentiality amongst the
group allows you to actually go to trust
each other for a start but it allows you
to test out different ideas that
sometimes I'm the sort of person that I
actually verbalize a lot of my ideas and
halfway through I'm thinking and
actually I don't agree with why stop and
say now anyway and and so it gives the
opportunity to feed prove it a bit like
myself to do that but as for this year's
um the way I've always felt in the past
that we it's been fairly successful I
compare it with is how other council
set their budgets and you know we were
able to turn to to get some ideas and
throw some ideas well we have the
figures we can have a chat and we can
sort out some some ideas prior to it
going for counsel but I have to say and
I may be the only one here things that I
thought this last one was almost a waste
of my time and the exercise I actually
didn't see the purpose of it maybe it
was just may not understanding what was
behind it but I couldn't glass what the
purpose of that exercise was and I
didn't get as much out this this last
away day as I have done in the last
night I did actually returned home quite
disappointed that mixed reception
Kessler mounting I just wanted to make a
comment I didn't pretend this away day
for a few reasons one of the reasons I
think there is a danger in when papers
are serviced private confidential and on
a political level one that there is a
strong majority in war party it tends to
have the appearance of a group meeting
you know is there is there a need to go
to the expense of hiring her face and
laying on a fine fare of food and when
sandwiches could be members could bigger
assemblages you talking about going to
an event where we're discussing
budgetary funding cuts may be in that
celestina secretive bit strained about
laying on a food runs the main point if
its private confidential then it is like
a group meeting potentially to political
rubies never getting out isn't a factor
of ten point what I buy I do agree about
the proper
complex or artwork bone versus Chatham
House rolls not I know there is a has
been discreet between people around what
chasm house balls mean I think whether
or not we agree what they mean I think
the rules there's described bughouse the
black would be more suitable personally
in that there's no temptation at
reputation if that's a word who says
well within the way that I think I think
those notes there i'm just going to be
able to the final thing in this then
which is for next year which is about
the public consultation because in our
papers we do can discreetly showing
percentages of public Ozil around the
public consultation but the figures who
respond right over a few hundred alone I
just remembers when he views using
social media I understand your social
media strategy now because the
budgeteers are seventy five thousand of
us mention complaints as well so i'm not
sure if that social media strategy will
include better budgetary consultation
there are some websites there are a
couple of websites and albans has a
actual very good internet interactive
website where people take part in a
public consultation on on the budget and
they get much better responses than we
do i don't know if it was belief in
swear their constant i'm coming back on
that over the years we've always have
public transportations whether it's
Parish District County governmentally
and it's up to the person and the people
that get the papers is they want it and
I'm not talking about this although i do
use it now as some of you already know
with a lot of spelling this paper but
i'm getting there but there is still an
awful lot of people out there that don't
use this that don't listen to whatever
is Twitter or whatever is I don't even
know what it means but at the end of the
day the public consultation it goes to
every house through Rochford matters
and in people feel they want to fill it
in there fill it in we can't make
anybody for it in the only thing even I
would like to see it was compulsory
voting but he can't have it but what I
am saying it is entirely up to the
individual and those people that have
answered it and put it back that might
only be point one percent of the other
people but these marriage people to come
back the rest of them are quite happy
with what they're doing and everything
else so I'm sorry but public
consultation is up to the public
themselves when they do it and when we
have a howdy day with the local a group
of people coming in and and at the end
of that not every one of those 50 people
that come actually do write anything at
all that they come they listen and
they've read it and at the end of the
day it purely a personal thing if you
want to answer it or not and I think
that to justice able to cross only 300
people answer but that's their
prerogative I met but I must think he's
all right if I have an ounce of it sorry
but in public and that's the other side
of every other comments no I agree with
Heather if people want to answer they
were also so then squidgy is decided
that the consultation is fine aimed
really be there thank you very much for
coming we've got a couple more things go
through that your fulfill fridge and
Spain or to be making quick
recognize somebody may be okay the open
so we're not going to confirm or 216
table there are 19 to use being taken a
moment so your document 7 um done will
be done today was causal budgets I think
everything we've done is it's all
details there we go and next month we
had car parking income so they don't
assess how much difference the
increasing terrorist has made his penis
was full after it's been above or below
yeah and then we also going to be doing
homelessness and i will call bounces
from the ground or be responses they
have any ideas rape victims have I
thought it'd be quite useful we want to
a moment Annie's we're asking God for
Housing Association it also liked across
Genesis and obviously we've got a
relationship in portrait Housing
Association the direct their imitator
that's indicated she's happy to detain
people now know how to make people
attend but we also only done Genesis to
attend us they're also quite lovely in
the area and obviously we would like
them to have have an indication of the
sort of questions that would they're
going to be asked so they can see the
relevance of it to them to encourage
them to
so should I ask the question you're
talking about homelessness right yeah
well homelessness the housing
associations are there to provide homes
for people but the homeless this part of
it is not their job their job is to run
the units as i see it for people to live
in what so where did the homelessness
come to that part of it very in mind
that presumably if something is already
in a housing association of the property
and they want to change over that that
comes through them it doesn't come
through us at all if they can go back
and change as many times as they want to
bearing in mind i had a holiday last
year where three people were on the
coach and they've all been watch with
housing and they were all telling me not
known who I was which was a change that
it's lovely because we didn't like this
one we've gone somewhere else and we've
got somewhere else and then swapped
around over a period of time so the
homelessness part who and we're going to
actually speak to about that because
it's not the housing in to help how we
find the homelessness and that part of
it and I think Egypt is that part we
should have somebody here but it's from
that area well as well such as heart
maybe or our variable relations have
less to do discussions who's going to
represent the area with regard to
housing associations they do have a duty
to provide temporary accommodation
certainly rotted housing as provide
separate accommodation to the district
council needs for homelessness but then
it squared around but that's enough warm
enough for his the right in the right
place and now perhaps subside with your
homeless you might feel you might need
temporary accommodation before you get
your opponent okay so that's why present
for housing associations I know I'm
coming back and I'm sorry about it but
it's something I'll feel very strongly
about in the sense that so many people
have got homelessness and they come into
the district oh they live in the
district and
and they need to go somewhere and
immediately the first thing they're told
will go and find somewhere private and
then and do it that way and um so I
really feel that we ought to speak to
people and say okay fair enough it's a
hundred family they haven't paid their
brains and everything else and they've
been thrown out then I've got quite a
number of people that's where all of her
that where people can't manage their
money and their affairs and made them
out but on that and making themselves
homeless because they can't cope with
their lives and I looking pretty girl
like that and that's where i'd like to
see somebody we speak to people on that
level not that with the housing
associations are going to take them in
but where else and how do they how do
they come about to actually do it I'm
sorry but it's something that I feel
very strongly about this you taught us
released at moment perhaps mental great
afterwards and don't you get your idea
I'm Katherine yeah i mean i'm not quite
sure what what it is you want you're
trying to say but with the homelessness
there's a number of reasons why people
become homeless in the district you know
people are being released from from
hospitals I on a personal friend i
worked at hospital
the adolescent you know there's a lot of
youngsters there that can't go back home
but they can't be released from the
hospital until they've got somewhere
somewhere to stay and we have a cutie of
care because you know they're not all
our residents but love them are our
residents you're certain situations we
go with domestic violence families
splitting up so there are a number of
reasons why people do become homeless
and yeah we do they are out there are
residents and we have a 20 of care for
them to try and see you know if we can
house them I mean it's nothing worse
than somebody being well enough to be
released from hospital but can't be
released from hospital because they've
got nowhere to go because that's not
going to help their mental health or
their physical health or talk so the
questions could be around where where do
we have a motion before then what are we
have information so that's nice yeah and
I can't get housing association race but
it could be something that could abolish
with the district council because
councilman peers will be here along with
them Steve Neville as well he won't so
ideally we trying to get stained sure
you were big in for that and then there
be two others been offshore yet who's
down to our I think I understand what
you mean around it has the Dean but I'm
having soldier outside but all I'm going
to say what basically said that is part
of what I'm trying to get out because
that isn't that is the most important
part and i am the other side of all this
you've got the youngsters but you've got
elderly people i'll try i'm an old girl
of our policy and that old but there we
are but where i'm coming from there are
lots of people older people that go into
hospital and their hospital as soon as
you board your chokes out the door at
the hospital it's nothing to do with the
hospital anymore and that's something
but it is homelessness as well there so
I hope that when we actually have this
discussion that they are taken jointly
old young and middle
yes Jerry Jerry the idea is to try and
get an idea of what the problem is if
there is a problem if there is no
problem how we as a district deal with
the problem if we do understand the
problem and I think it's very helpful
that we've got counselor this is butcher
cause I think you're much more aware
than officers and what happens and I
think we counselor Pearson is the book
very is very help as well to get a
really good idea that we have has to
understand it and if we can help chasm
increasingly not confirm the odinsword
output but also to see what other
outside parties if that agrees with what
we as a council thing that happens or if
they're actually linking up very well if
there are problems really around there
so that is quite wide ranging i think i
think is very important we try and get
some questions across to tell you so um
what happens with people that don't
really show up on the radar where
they're living with friends or simple
something yes I know there must be quite
a number of those people yeah there is
but that powder they receive Pell
published they don't go out and ask for
it they can remain in that situation for
months or years accountant normal think
that is a question exactly and gossip
wishes are there any mail to talk let's
bring that's the sort of thing we want
Basu question so we can draw out the
answers and I think that's one of the
problems where um a lot of their how
many saw him and I think we're talking
about young people and that say when I
was talking about mental health and
hospitals I wasn't just talking about
young people over certainly with younger
people with sofa surfing they will go
from one friend to another 21 relatively
or another and there are lots like that
and some of them some of it starts at a
very young age you know our other we'll
see youngsters a 14 or that are not um
don't have a permanent place of living
I'm a response new parents a response of
course they are if parents are giving up
that responsibility then we have a
responsibility to ensure that those
people are careful and I think a lot of
the homeless in that age group are are
hidden we need to be aware of that I've
been having things in place to support
them Catholic Drake MGMT supported
clarification we ought to have a duty of
care but we also have a statutory
responsibility get low give me know yes
we didn't hear as counselors thank you
for that Miss Raven since the other that
side of it there's also a diesel of
contemporary home is where we fire or
flood or str8 Lee knows a lot better
then he's another source and he ok
emerge very quickly and suddenly both
the families or whatever area offices to
actually do believe though maybe about
one of my residents they had a fire in
their home and they were for a short
period they stayed with relations and
then an insurance company paid for their
hotel accommodation which went on for
about six months that are they a feature
of homelessness or two they register on
on the figures or that's a great i don't
know we're not here to discuss it bother
you so i think they're not insured then
yes they've got to come to councils say
if we haven't put questions forward then
we can maybe some of the questions may
become one question they might
like what okay but one of the things
that does concern me about homelessness
as well and XP is a domestic violence
situations where and it's often women
and children are fleeing a home there is
a really difficult situation for
families for women and their children
and sometimes they need to flee and they
need to be put in a safe environment
away from the district but quite often
it would be far better that they were
housed within their the same area
children can continue at the name school
with their friends that there's the
support structure for them to the mother
with her friends and everything but to
have to be put out of our district
because that's the only accommodation I
think that is wrong yeah and quite
frequently I think Owens they usually
it's the main booster the problem and
normally the main is the one with a
tenancy agreement quite often which
means they I think they're never getting
that rock pounding governess big
dropping around the fact that the man
may have the agreement talk by building
therefore they contract very to toward
the knees very usable lot different
about it sorry when i specially but
that's the one days later but start
think about 90 occasions to go eat
freedom craigory metrics hospice they
were gonna do that project aims purely
control of
yeah another one first off I think next
year it's obviously I was we haven't
managed to do anything about so don yeah
things well not in the market looking
inspecting there regularly inspecting
apart very boring eventually because not
having to think about items we want what
we can't enforce them on actually a bit
might be thing to come up this year we
think be expanded next year that it's an
idea for the next meeting first mate for
those items program they're not bound by
it is my understanding this group
project teams building control I'm sure
we are going to try and arrange a
meeting with mr. Dave around this that's
been golf ball I'm going off to my
shoulder by CT contractor my pants is
this thursday so happy that be that the
meeting we finalize is that Roger of
district matters job group always been
saying 19 to comment at camp time no
one's come back to me but I'm sure
someone will eventually so if they
didn't understand what are you he's
talking about the what strip matters yes
so what do you say well it's why are you
having their bid to find out what they
what they get up to what they don't get
up to the war they sent a number of
paintings already any spare bears come
back we're all back to us
the the lots of scoping document or
remember it was around popularity change
a format possible i believe ya discussed
so that was it is being mention of
previous meetings for that they haven't
reported better shape than that but
they'll be in it we couldn't we have
completed out yeah that'd be the next PT
sorry I teen chick on has been run he
was the vine pads end zone blocking
software which is thursday better we've
now combined the two because it seemed
to be point seven hundred second ones
the measured critical to possibly
rotational yeah and that's it comes
Morgan very much